ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد انتقد وزير
الخارجيه اليوناني تركيا بعد ان هدد رئيس
تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان بضرب اثنا بصور خبر
السياسيه وقال الوزير اليونانيس ان تهديد
عضو بحلف شمال الاطلسي الناتو بيجن هجوم
صاروخ على بلاده غير مقبولنا
واضاف في تصريح على حساب على تويتر ان يجب
عدم السماح بدخول اساليب كوريا الشماليه
الى حلفنيته وكان رئيس تركيا اردوغان قال
ان بلاده لن تقف مكتوفه الايدي اذا استمرت
اليونان فيما سماه تسليح جسوري بحريجه
مضيفا ان اختباراته لصاروخ بالسيوف خوفا
اليونانا
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفينا من اسطنبول
المحلل السياسي المصري الدكتور عبد اللطيف
درويش استاذ واداره الازمات والصرعات
الدوليه اهلا بكم
ان ابدا من اسطنبول معك يا دكتور
لماذا بدا الرئيس التركي
عن الصواريخ البالستيه قريبه المدى يتحدث
على الضفه
لم نسمع تصريحات يونانيه هو وحده تحدث عن
اليونان وقال بان هذه الصواريخ قد تخيف
اليونانيين وهي فعلا قادره على اخافتهم
لماذا المبادره بطرح مثل هكذا مخاوف
تحيه طيبه مساء الخير في الحقيقه المبادره
لم تكن من اردوغان بيل ااا يعني اعتقد كان
يقصد اردوغان اييي تحضير اليونان من مغبه
الاستمرار في طريق
الاستفزازات
والتحدي لتركيا يعني الاستفاده
الاستفزازات تاتي دائما من اثينا تقوم
بتسليح الجزر غير عسكريه همم منتهي كده
القانون الدولي والاتفاقيات التي بموجبها
تم تسليم سياده هذه الجزر الملتصقه
بالصواحل التركيه الى الجانب اليوناني هذه
الانتهاكات وهذا التصعيد يزعج بكل تركيا
همم اخر الحديث كان حول تركيا جربت صاروخا
محليا باليستيا محليا همم
ثارت همم نقاش
احلى في هذا التفاعل الصغير لماذا تركيا
تحرم على غيرها ما تحلله لنفسها تركيا
تصنع اليوم وتركيا همم
تتفاوض اليوم في صفقات اسلحه كبيره فلماذا
تعتبر بان اليونان اذا اشترت اسلحه او
تعاقدت مع اي دوله اخرى فهذا سيكون همم
موجها لتركيا سيكون همم محاوله لاخافه
تركيا
لا يحشد هذه
الاسلحه على الحدود التركيه اليونانيه هذا
من جانب كذلك هذه الجذور سيده الكريمه
بموجب الاتفاقيات اتفاق اللوزه عام 23 من
القرن الماضي همم من قرن همم وكذلك اتفاق
باريس عام سبعه وهمم وسبعه واربعين همم
عدم التسليح وعسكرتها هذه الجزر هذه الجزر
كانت تابعه لتركيا
احتلت القوه الاستعماريه الغربيه ايطاليا
ثم تسليمها الى تركيا دون ااه
تسليمها
همم
امر صحيح
لكن حتى اجانب المقابل دكتور عبد اللطيف
لما حاول الرد على تصريحات الرئيس التركي
استشهد بتوجهات كوريا الشماليه الزوج
بتوجهات كوريا الشماليه
ونعلم كلنا تفاصيل التوجهات الكوريه
الشماليه فيها كذا تبادل تصريحات ما الذي
يقصد يقصده وزير الخارجيه اليوناني ما
الذي تعنيه اليونان من هكذا تصريحات
الذي يقصده
الى حرب مع تركيا بس يكون قرار برلمان
اليوناني وليس قرار رئيس الوزراء لوحده
هذا هي الفرق في التركيب التركيب
الديمقراطيه لدوله يعني عمرها اكثر من
ثلاثه الاف سنه لديها بني ديمقراطيه
فبالتالي ليست المزاجيه الفرديه ولا
السائل الفوز في الانتخابات لتصريحات غير
مسؤوله بقصف كثير ولكن رغم ان الانتخابات
بسيطه في الجزء اليونا يمكن ان تقصف المدن
التركيه اذا جئنا بهذه المنطقه لكن احنا
هنا لا نتحدث عن لعبه كره قدم نتحدث عن
حرب
واذكركم ايضا انا كمان ابلغكم انه تم
زياده كمان الحشد العسكري على الحدود
البريه والحدود اس دخول المدن التركيه من
المنطقه واعره في الجانب اليوناني في
منطقه اكسانتي وما شبه ذلك فبالتالي يجب
على السياسيين هنا يفكرون في الدخول بحرب
ان يفكر بعد السكان بلدهم التي قد تؤدي
الى ضحيه الان افضل على تركيا انتم افكر
بمصير الليره التركيه
والتي انحذرت وايجاد حل الفقراء الذين لا
يستطيعون ما رايك
تصريحات تطلقها عبثا لخدمه الانتخابات
وتصريحات غير مسؤوله لانها قد تقود
المنطقه الى حرب همم لن يكون فيها الرابح
بحسب همم دكتور عبد اللطيف
اولا يعني
الاشاره بالليره التركيه والصعوبات
الاقتصاد عليه ان اييه يشير الى الاقتصاد
اليوناني معاني
الحشد العسكري على الحدود
هناك
القوه معروف الجميع لا يقبل القياس بين
تركيا واليونان هذا من جانب من جانب الاخر
لا احد يتمنى الحرب رغم هذه همم
التصعيد الكلام او الخطابات
للسياسيين احيانا وكذلك لم يكن اردوغان
يهدد اليونان بلبل حذر اليونان من مغبه
الاستمرار بهذا بطريق الاستفزاز همم
والاستدعاء الاطراف الثالثه ضد تركيا كلما
كان في الامر تحضير اليونان
كذلك يجب التذكره اليونان وتركيا في اطار
حلف همم شمال الاطلسي وهناك توازنات ورغم
كل هذه التوترات همم التي همم يعني تتكرر
والتصعيد لن تكون هناك اي همم حرب ولا
نتمنى ذلك
همم يعني قاعده سعيد همم
ما قلتها بالضبط وجدته اقتباسه لانقله
لضيفه ما رايك دكتور عبد اللطيف
دكتور عبد اللطيف يبدو باننا فقدنا
الاتصال لا عاد لنا دكتور عبد اللطيف
تسمعني
يسمعني
اليونان هي التي تسرعت في الرد على هذه
التصريحات في الواقع اردوغان لم يهدد
ولكنه حذر من عمليه التسليح التي تقوم بها
اثينا
يعني
تركيا تركيا
الجزيره
بعد الاستفزازات التركيه والتجاوزات
التركيه على الصعيد الجوي البحري وهمم
الطلعات التي يقوم بها فبالتالي هي عباره
عن رده فعل لليونان ولكن اذا اي دوله يهدد
رئيسها يجب ان تاخذ تهديدات على محمل الجد
ايه ولكن
الكثيره فلا تتوقع الكثير
اها هذه لازم يرد عليها دكتور يعني مصر
ما رايك دكتور والجاجعه منذ قليل
ربطها ضيفي بالانتخابات في الواقع
والله انا اقول هذا الكلام للطرف اليوناني
لان يوميا اليونان يقوم ويستيقظ على على
الاخبار التركيه
وبالتهديد التركي المفترات هناك فوبيا
واضحه لدى الجانب اليوناني
فوبيا تركيا للاسف الشديد
هذا السؤال الثاني بموضوع الانتخابات
فقط
لان موضوع الانتخابات لم ياتي فقط مع
موضوع اليونان اتى مع العمليه السوريه
شمالا اتام عن موضوع
التسليح اليوناني اتمع اكثر من موضوع في
كل مره يقال بانه حتى في العمليه
الارهابيه للاسف التي شهدت اسطنبول يقال
دائما بانه التصريحات التحركات همم تحركات
رئيس اردوغان تقود دائما لمصلحه
الانتخابات ما رايك
يعني صحيح في تركيا انتخابات خلال سته
اشهر وكذلك في اليونان اييه وهناك
السياسيين يستغلون فوبيا تركيا اكثر هذا
من جانب من جانب الاخر هذه القضايا سيده
الكريمه سواء كان العمليات العسكريه او
محاربه الارهاب في سوريا او التوترات
التركيه همم اليونانيه والتصعيد بين
الطرفين همم غير مرتبطه بشكل مباشر
بالانتخابات هذا التوتر كان قائم قبل ثلاث
سنوات قبل سنتين كذلك تركيا قامت همم
عمليات همم عده عمليات في سوريا في
اطار محاربه الارهاب لا يعني لا يجب ربط
كل شيء بالانتخابات
اتمنى ان تكون دوله طبيعيه وانت تحترم
سياده العراق على الموصل وعلى اربيل ان
تتمنى ان تكون دوله طبيعيه ولا تقطعوا
المياه عن سوريا باسلو هو مضاد ضد القانون
الدولي اتمنى ان تكون دوله طبيعيه وان
تحترموا سياده اليونان على ارضها على جزر
من اسطنبول المحل السياسي المصري
اداره الازمات والصرعات الدوليه لنقاش
مشاهدنا دائما باقي ايام السلام عليكم